when the intergalactic megalomaniac
Thanos came face-to-face with the
quick-witted nanotech fitted Iron Man in
Avengers infinity war their conversation
didn't quite play out how fans may have
expected it to rather than watching as
the hulking purple villain questioned to
the armored Avenger was viewers saw
Thanos instantly recognized Tony Stark
by name as the man inside the red and
gold getup
fans of the Marvel Cinematic Universe
have already come up with more
explanations as to how the nose seems to
have known Tony prior to infinity war
than we can count
and another intriguing idea has just
been added to the mix building off of
what the film's co-directors Joe and
Anthony Russo previously said about the
character's relationship one Reddit user
has theorized that Thanos and Tony
actually met before the events of
infinity war but before anyone rattles
off a list of reasons as to why that's
impossible
wait until you hear the other half of
the theory the idea goes that Thanos and
Tony will meet again and fight an
Avengers for do you Kinnear Alton an
encounter that technically happens in
the past so far most people have
accepted that Thanos recognizes Tony
from the final fight in Avengers 1
remembering him as one of the heroes who
stopped his original plan for gathering
the Infinity stones even though he
wasn't on the ground to witness air it's
a perception that would seem to be
bolstered by comments from the Russo
brothers on the Infinity war commentary
track but they said fans recognize Tony
from the original battle of New York as
a person who indid the plan but if the
fourth Avengers movie really does delve
into time travel then perhaps Thanos is
remembering a Battle of New York or some
other fight that we don't know about yet
the theory posits that the Avengers will
defeat Thanos by traveling through time
- before it's infinity war victory doing
battle with him in the past before the
events of the third Avengers even happen
interpreted that way fellow-student
Finity war is meeting the avengers again
while from their point of view they're
meeting him for the first time
this theory is attention-grabbing for
sure but when you take a step back and
look at the Avengers for rumor mill as a
whole you'll realize that the idea
sounds pretty familiar back in June not
long after infinity war opened in
theaters for its record-setting run
screenrant's Thomas bacon posted his own
theory about Thanos Tony and time travel
bacon hypothesized there's strong
evidence that Avengers 4 explores the
idea of time travel with the surviving
Avengers traveling back to the past as
such it's entirely possible
could have met a future Tony Stark going
one step further this may well explain
my Thanos snarls I hope they remember
you perhaps he already knows when stark
will finally die because he's seen it
happen while the theory has mutated a
little bit since the home release of
Avengers infinity war they're still
enough to it to warrant some
consideration with set photos from
Avengers 4 clearly showing battlefields
from previous movies it's totally
possible that the end game will see Tony
duking it out with Thanos and an
alternate timelines past Marvel is one
of the most secretive studios out there
so despite how spoiler happy Tom Holland
and Mark Ruffalo have been in the past
fans shouldn't expect anyone involved
with the fourth Avengers movie to start
spitting truths about this particular
time-travel theory or any other Avengers
4 theory for that matter for the time
being the Marvel loving masses can
either immerse themselves in the weird
and wonderful world of fun theories
believing a new possible storyline for
Avengers 4 every week
or they can take the Russo brothers word
at face value and patiently wait for the
answers just like everybody else either
way all shall be revealed when Avengers
4 opens in theaters on May 3rd 2019